[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK, now we're
at the Museum of Developer Art,
and I'm standing
here with Alex, who
actually curated the pieces
we're about to take a look at.
Alex, can you tell
me a little bit
about why you chose these
pieces for a developer festival?
ALEX: So the two
artists who are here,
Ezra Miller and Vincent Jose
are both developers themselves
and artists.
And so their work is
really about using code
to create beautiful,
natural simulations.
Vincent creates
fluid dynamics that
are interactive, which is
a very hard thing to do.
And Ezra creates data viz--
sorry, data visualizations, that
are essentially transforming
into flocking starlings.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And why these
pieces at this festival?
ALEX: So I wanted
to find artists
that could understand
the developer mentality,
and communicate to
developers, and show
that by using developer
tools, you can still
create really beautiful work.
So that's really
the main reason.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Well, we were looking
at them earlier,
and that really comes through.
Thank you so much.
ALEX: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
I'm standing here
with [? Vincent ?]
in front of his art.
Now, I have a few questions.
It's amazing, and I
really need to know more.
But first, can you tell me just
a little bit about this piece,
your process making
it, what you used,
and what it represents to you?
SPEAKER 1: So this piece is
called "Fluid Structure."
It's an exploration of how
liquid-like shapes form,
deform, and react under
various forces and stimuli.
So I've been fascinated for a
long time by fluid dynamics,
because you see it
everywhere in nature,
like streams, rivers,
smoke, and volcanoes,
and it's all this incredible
variety of motion,
very intricate.
And historically, it's been
very computationally expensive.
But now, recent
progress makes it
possible to do the
simulation real-time,
and that makes it
very exciting for me
to build interactive pieces
using this technology.
Also, to explore all
kinds of different--
how it's going to react
playing with different forces,
and what happens if we
slow the time down, or make
it really fast.
And I think it seems
familiar and both mysterious,
because we're used to how
things react to physics laws.
So I think one of the challenges
for this piece was the scale
and making it interactive
for a large number of people.
So it's using five
different Kinects,
which is a depth sensor that
can tell the main space where
the people are.
And it's computing forces
based on where people stand
to push the liquid around.
So that most people
who are not always
familiar with sensors and
interactive installation
would get it, there's
little hints--
you see your silhouette.
And some modes where
the water falls on you
is here to get your
interaction and how
you influence the
result. And, I think,
watching the people tonight,
it was a premier for me
as well, too.
I tested it with a few
friends, but it's like,
what are people going to do,
and how are they going to react?
And a lot of people are
already getting into it,
and that's pretty
amazing to see that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK, so one
more thing is, the size of this
is massive.
And I don't know what your
studio space looks like,
but I presume you did
some prototyping that
wasn't this big before.
How did you conceptualize
a piece this large?
SPEAKER 1: So I was lucky
I could prototype a smaller
slice, and then I used
VR and Oculus to--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Really?
SPEAKER 1: --get a feel for
the scale of the piece, which
I had done in the past for
other art installations
which were also
pretty big-scale.
And I'm based in New
York, so large spaces
are a rare thing to get.
So VR for me is really useful
to get a sense of scale.
And the other thing is
that since everything
is running real-time, I
have a number of parameters
I can adjust quickly once I see
the piece for the first time
on site at scale,
which I did tonight.
So I slowed down some
things and tweaked
some timings make it better.
So that's the two ways
I worked on this scale.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Well, thank you so much for
sharing your art with us.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, you're welcome.
Thanks.
It's great to be here and
have this opportunity.
And thanks to Alex for curating
this medium of developer art.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK, now we're looking
at the second piece,
and this one is by Ezra.
Ezra, could you tell us
a little bit about this?
EZRA: Yeah, so what
we have here is
my piece "Data Murmuration,"
which I built using WebGL,
so it's just running
in the browser.
And it's a flocking
simulation as well as
a data visualization.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So one of
the things that I notice
about the piece
is you definitely
have something to say about
the really clear data that
shows up every once in
a while on this graph,
but then it breaks out
all these data points
into this flocking behavior.
What brought you to
that artistic choice?
EZRA: So it oscillates
between this sort
of formless cloud of birds
swarming and then this really
well-defined graph.
I think to me,
it's trying to get
at questions about whether
humanity can organize itself
as we face a lot of
problems as a society.
And I think the difference
between this formless, swirling
cloud and that get at that idea.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right, man.
Hey, let's talk a little
bit more about the tech,
since we're at the
developer conference.
You said this is in the browser?
EZRA: Yeah, so I make
websites using WebGL.
This was built with three.js,
which is the go-to WebGL
library, and I use it in
all of my work, pretty much.
And it's built
using shaders, which
are programs that run
on a computer's GPU that
let you do computations a
lot faster than on the CPU.
And it's basically creating
everything procedurally, which
means there's no real
image textures being used
or any other real assets.
I think the main
asset is the data,
and then everything
comes from that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And I
also noticed, in addition
to the flocking, there's
this almost waterfall effect.
What is that?
EZRA: Right, I actually
added that in recently
before we set up.
I think it just adds
a little more dynamism
to the background, cuts
through the clouds.
It's a feedback
loop process, which
is something I use in all
of my work, pretty much.
Yeah, I just thought--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's
leave it at that mystery.
I like that.
All right, Ezra.
Thank you so much for sharing
your work with us today.
EZRA: Thanks, man.
I really appreciate it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Wow.
All right, so I'm here
at the VR drive-in,
and I'm standing
with [? Sarah, ?]
who actually helped build the
experiences that attendees
are going through right now.
Can you tell me a
little bit about what
they're experiencing?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, so we're
Google Spotlight Stories,
and we are creating
content that directors
create their own
stories in this medium.
So we have "Pearl"
by Patrick Osborne,
which was nominated
for an Academy Award
this year for Best
Animated short film.
And we have the Gorillaz'
newest music video,
which is the first music
video for our group.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now, you worked
with the production teams
and the artists in building
these experiences, right?
SPEAKER 2: Yes, yes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
What's that like?
Do they have all
sorts of questions?
What's different from a
normal production experience?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, it's definitely
a new medium for most people,
but both took to it very well.
You have to think
about creating a film
in 360 space a little
bit differently
than you would a
normal 2D narrative
film, so you have to make it
interesting in all directions,
if you will.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Very cool.
[? Sarah, ?] thanks so
much for joining us.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This has got to
be the largest foosball table I
have ever seen.
Look at this thing!
SPEAKER 3: [INAUDIBLE]!
[LAUGHING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Coming to
you live from the world
championships of pair ping
pong, here at Google I/O.
I'm just kidding,
we're having fun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, there's probably
something I could say,
but honestly, this
is just mini golf.
So I'm going to
go have some fun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What am I doing here?
SPEAKER 4: All right, so
it's a 360 video booth that
records high-frame slow motion.
So anything that
you do looks cool.
You get to share it right away.
Does that sound good?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 4: So the
main rule is, you
don't leave the
platform until I catch
the arm so you don't get hurt.
Other than that, you can
do anything that you want.
you can jump, move.
Moving quick is cool,
standing perfectly still
is cool, either way.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: But
don't move slow.
SPEAKER 4: Yeah, because
it'll be kind of melodramatic.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So like
a jump or something?
SPEAKER 4: Yeah, that'd be good.
You good to go?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
All right, I'm just
testing it out.
SPEAKER 4: I'll count you down.
3, 2, 1, go.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I don't
really know what's going on,
but I'm going to go with this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I am tuckered out.
[LAUGHING] Thanks for
joining me at the block party
here on the first
evening of Google I/O.
We saw a lot of
really cool stuff,
and I hope you had
as much fun as I did.
[MUSIC PLAYING]